right so let me just quickly introduce
you to the audience so Dr Brian Keating
is an experimental physicist at the
University of California San Diego he is
the best-selling author of two books
losing the Nobel Prize and into the
impossible he is also uh the host of the
podcast of the same name into the
impossible so once again Dr Keating
welcome to the podcast
it's great to be with you it's uh it's a
great honor and it's great to talk to
your millions of uh fans and and those
that depend on you for great information
of which I am one thank you for having
me
thank you so we're going to discuss a
whole lot of topics The Big Bang Theory
the origin of the universe uh
possibility of life in the universe
Multiverse and other things but let's
begin with topics related to the
research that you're doing so could you
give us a brief history of the universe
the the best model of the universe that
we have is the Big Bang cosmological
model the Lambda CDM model so could you
give the audience an overview how of how
the universe began how did it end up the
way it is today yeah uh so that's
actually a very timely question no pun
intended because people are debating
very very vociferously the origin of the
universe and whether or not it was a
singular one-time event whether it was a
Quantum event whether it was a classical
event that can be understood and whether
or not it was uh it was preceded by
another universe or perhaps accompanied
by not just one universe but it's called
in the Multiverse perhaps an infinite
number 10 to the 500 or more other
parallel universes and so in some sense
it's it's an unresolved question what we
do know is going backwards from today
the way you take today and we go
backwards
13.8 billion years we will come to a
very very different set of conditions in
the physical Universe we would have a
very hot very dense plasma suffused with
protons and neutrons neutrinos and other
subatomic particles
and that Epoch is really the end of
where we really understand physics based
upon laboratory experiments that we can
do today in fact that my colleagues do
at the Large Hadron Collider they can
replicate conditions going back 13.8
billion years
um with only a slight difference of
about a second or maybe even less than
one second from perhaps the origin of
time perhaps the origin of space perhaps
the origin of our universe but
definitely the beginning of what's
called our observable universe and our
observable universe are all the things
that have had enough time for their
existence to reach us via
electromagnetic
Rays or by the existence of subatomic
particles that we can still examine
today that era is called the Big Bang we
don't think of the Big Bang as
synonymous as equivalent to the origin
of time as professional cosmologist we
say that the origin of time may not be
understandable within the laws of
physics and yet we have a vast amount of
very technical quantitative detailed
understanding of the properties of the
Universe from that point in time second
fractions of a second
going forward now what my research
centers on is trying to go back even
further we've gone back in just 90 years
from what was thought to be an
infinitely old Universe a universe that
was thought to exist even by Einstein
for all eternity
and uh and we have now understood How
the Universe has been evolving not
static as Einstein initially thought and
that Revolution continues we're trying
to build instruments I'm not a theorist
I do not construct theories of wormholes
of black holes of other kinds of holes I
don't do any of that I Look to try to
prove my friends that make those
theories wrong not right we're not in
the business of proving somebody's
Theory right no we're in the business of
proving other people's theories wrong
and then what we're left with will be an
approximation to How the Universe came
to have the appearance that it does
today that's the job of the Big Bang
cosmologist of which I am one and what
we found is a universe filled with
matter obviously filled with radiation
of different types and we hopefully can
get into the different types of
radiation that includes neutrinos
photons gravitational waves and many
other uh forms of signals from the
earliest moments in the universe we see
a Universe that's Dynamic that's
expanding that every single object that
we can see is moving away from us to
very high approximation except for maybe
a dozen or two that are gravitationally
attached to the Milky Way galaxy
and we see a Universe that's suffused
with a leftover heat which is actually
quite cold and that's quite good for us
and I know you've talked about this many
times called The Cosmic microwave
background radiation
and that type of radiation has suffused
the cosmos it's cooled off from
thousands of degrees to just a mere
three degrees above what's called
absolute zero that is very precise
physical evidence that has revealed the
existence of not only ordinary matter
and radiation but Dark Matter dark
energy and the presence of many exotic
forms of matter and and radiation that
we can discuss today but more
importantly is that it's helped to help
us understand where other alternative
cosmologies infinitely old Universe
static Universe etc etc have changed and
on my channel
I like to pride myself that I talk about
alternative models that are precise in
their predictions right now there's a
lot of controversy going around saying
the Big Bang didn't happen and that
there's um there are other explanations
for all the phenomena and the big Bang's
in trouble thanks to the James Webb
Space Telescope which I hope we can chat
about and nothing of the sort could be
close to the truth we actually have more
confidence in the origin of the universe
emerging from a big bang not necessarily
a singularity Another Universe we have
to discuss that but we have more
confidence in the quantitative not
qualitative quantitative description of
nature then um than we've ever had and
on my channel I discuss with other
esteemed colleagues the proof or
disproof of the standard model and how
we can adjust it to better match
observations perhaps by bringing in
things like the Multiverse uh
quasi-steady States things like that but
perhaps not so that's a description of
what I do for a living I build
telescopes I've been to the Antarctic
South Pole twice to build a telescope
called bicep and with my colleagues and
now with my colleagues in Chile we're
building a hundred million dollar uh
Cosmic microwave background Observatory
to look for the imprint of waves of
gravity on the waves of light emanating
throughout the universe so that's my
daily job
so let's talk about the CMB the cosmic
cosmological microwave background
radiation so the cosmological redshift
distance relation and the CMB are two
major pieces of evidence that provide
very strong support for The Big Bang
Theory now this new the new observations
from the jwst the James Webb Telescope
have caused the controversy so what's
this new raging controversy all about
and how do the jwst observations of the
earliest galaxies supposedly prove that
the Big Bang Theory is incorrect
yes so um I liken it to the situation in
physics and in astronomy in 1968 so in
1968 uh was before humans landed on the
moon and we were trying to understand
the origin of the solar system in
particular how did the earth form how
did the moon form and what were the
other origins of the planetary
conditions that caused our solar system
to look the way it does
in 1968 we had very little physical
evidence because we hadn't had
astronauts scoop into the moon and bring
back pieces of it here to Earth and so
we lack hard physical evidence we had a
lot of observations now the um once we
went there then we refined our model of
the lunar formation Theory and it's
still a theory we can't prove it there
were no video cameras there was no live
streaming of the event uh but we think
it was due to a large Collision of a a
very very large planetary sub planetary
body crashed into the Earth the
primordial Earth and dissociated it
fragmented it and we see object uh uh
properties similar to the crust of the
Earth in the entirety of the Moon in
other words the moon doesn't have a
solid iron core and doesn't have uh
liquid you know surrounding that inner
core and those are things that the Earth
has that the moon doesn't have so it it
is likely that it didn't form via
um you know capture or or the exact same
processes that form the Earth probably
formed from a collision now is that
proof no but we have good evidence for
it now you wouldn't say
that that Discovery then invalidates
Isaac Newton's laws of gravity which
underpin the solar system planetary
formation you wouldn't say oh well the
Moon is too um is too big to have gotten
that way and therefore not only is your
theory of of formation of of an
astrophysical object namely the Moon Not
only is that wrong Babaji but it's
completely wrong your notion of gravity
and condensation and actually there's
some other force uh electricity that's
holding the moon so that's what's
happening with this recent controversy
there's a claim that the formation of
galaxies with slightly more structure
about a billion years after the big bang
has called into question not just the
Big Bang itself but the theory of
relativity the gravitational properties
of of matter and all a host of other
objects and not only that according to
the main proponent of it
but um but it is evidence for a theory
that's been ruled out literally for 90
years called the tired light hypothesis
which in their model they assume a
static universe
and they're saying in a static Universe
obviously there's an infinite amount of
time for Galaxies to have their uh
spiral structures that are observed in
some of the James Webb Space Telescope
data now I've done two videos now
including one with my colleague as a
professor in Sydney and Jared Lewis
Garrett Lewis and uh refutation of this
idea and the primary way to understand
it is that the web telescope simply
cannot look back to an early Epoch pre-4
galaxies formed because it is sensitive
to infrared light just as Hubble
couldn't look back as far as James Webb
can look back because it was limited
it's electromagnetic spectrum and I know
you talked about the electromagnetic
spectrum about a week ago on a similar
uh show and so I won't belabor it but
the electromagnetic spectrum is an
infinite distribution of photon
characteristics and the Hubble had
slight amount of infrared capability but
not much James Webb is designed to do
that to specifically look for highly
redshifted light due to the expansion of
the universe evolving and increasing
over time such that galaxies that are
farther away are moving faster away and
therefore are more Doppler shifted and
therefore are more red now of course
when you have a new technology you see
things you couldn't see with the earlier
technology when Galileo used the
telescope for the first time in 1609 he
looked up
and he saw things that you couldn't see
with the naked eye he didn't go back and
say maybe all the laws of science need
to be overthrown because uh it's simply
not possible in my limited comprehension
to develop a moon around Jupiter now
it's impossible like it would take too
long and no he didn't say that at all he
said let me investigate the capability
of this new instrument so with James
Webb we have zero evidence for the
income incompatibility of The Big Bang
Theory in fact it's more evidence than
than one could have previously even
collected using the Hubble telescope so
I think it's almost it's almost
anti-scientific to say that this now
calls into question the Believers in
this uh alternative model suggests the
universe is not expanding it they
suggest that the Universe cannot evolve
to form galaxies in such a short amount
of time and they misconstrue what the
big bang actually says the Big Bang
doesn't say anything about the formation
of galaxies oh and as a bonus apogee
they they have a theory of
um the uh the universe that's completely
incompatible at what's called a hundred
standard deviations or more with
observations they have no explanation
for the cosmic microwave background
radiation and worst of all this is a
sociological point which I know you talk
about science and Society they are
calling into question the intellectual
honesty and integrity of my colleagues
now I don't work on the web telescope
I've interviewed the chief scientist who
won the Nobel Prize John Mather and many
other people involved in it and
including the people that wrote this
paper that has been cited as evidence
supposedly against the Big Bang
and um and they accuse me of being blind
and ignorant about alternative models
because I'm making my money
from The Big Bang Theory and I don't
even really respond but I did want to uh
I posted on my um my video
um that's the video for people that
haven't subscribed to my channel Dr
Brian Keating I posted an interview with
one of the most renowned cosmologists in
history his name is Giant narlicar and
if you haven't met him Abhijit you
should meet him he's at Puna he and his
wife mangala are some of the brightest
intellects in the world I actually had
the honor of meeting giant many times
here at UC San Diego why because the
person whose office that I inhabit today
uh his name is Jeffrey Burbage or was he
passed away in 2010. he and his wife
Margaret Burbage along with Willie
Fowler and um and Fred Hoyle who came up
with the name Big Bang as an insult
because they didn't believe in the Big
Bang giant was one of Fred hoyle's
students his best student at Cambridge
um phenomenal intellect giant still
believes in What's called the
quasi-steady state universe and if you
have any doubt about my intellectual
honesty or my willingness to consider
alternatives watch that video with giant
it's pinned on my on my channel he is
and his wife are delightful truly
intellectually honest brilliant
scientist and mathematician in her case
and
I have no problem talking to them why
because they don't cast aspersions on my
Integrity they speak in the most
quantitative possible terms they don't
have polemics they are true Scholars and
so that was kind of my subtle response
to this people saying
don't trust Keating don't trust his
colleagues don't even trust the web
telescope we have the right idea oh and
by the way these people
their main goal is to support Fusion
research that they're doing privately
funded luckily uh that they're they
happen to have the secret to the
universe according to them uh and they
can reveal it if they get more money and
so if anybody has a financial ulterior
motive it's not me
[Laughter]
so talking about alternative models to
the Big Bang what would you consider to
be the strongest uh arguments in
opposition to the big bang I mean for
instance there is the the one of the
examples is that the Big Bang Theory
depends on the cosmic inflation
hypothesis the theory that the outset
the universe expanded superluminally so
is there any experimental for evidence
for inflation if there is none then does
it mean that that's an argument against
the Big Bang what would you say
yeah so there's a difference that we
have to distinguish between cosmology
which is the evolution and or of the
universe and Cosmo cosmoginy which is
the Genesis or cosmogenesis
um so imagine you study the theory of
evolution and you say well we don't have
an explanation which is true we don't
have an explanation for the origin of
life not only on Earth but in the
universe and actually Fred Hoyle Giant
and Arlo car's advisor had some ideas
about this as well we can talk about
that some other time
but the idea that you could invalidate
Darwin's theory or you could call into
question the theory of evolution which
depends on genetic um uh Evolution and
genetic heritability of of chromosomes
and traits that you could invalidate
Darwin because we don't have an
explanation to have a life got started
on Earth
um is not fully intellectually honest in
my opinion
um and so it is true that we lack an
explanation for the very origin T equals
zero the moment of time at which
everything came into existence it is
also true we lack a theory of what's
called quantum gravity where we don't
understand the reconciliation
of how the laws of gravity mainly
manifest on classical very large scales
and the laws of the quantum can interact
in a self-consistent way we don't
understand that's true and in fact there
may be no such Theory of Everything
t-o-e That might not exist we assume
that it may exist many of my colleagues
have looked for it Einstein look for it
we still haven't found it
um and that's because it may not exist
or it may be at such high energy scales
will never have access to it either way
despite those lacunae those gaps in our
understanding it does not question the
underlying Evolution and origin of
matter that we observe that happens long
after the moment of time remember and
you know this but physicists don't think
of time linearly we don't we don't say
oh a um you know one second after the
big bang is the same as you know 300
seconds after the big bang is the same
as 9 000 seconds no we think
logarithmically or exponentially we're
trying to go right now from an
understanding of the universe say at 10
to the minus nine seconds the time is
inversely proportional to temperature of
the universe so at that time at a time
about one nanosecond after the origin of
our observable universe that could have
been because of previous Universe
collapsed it could have been because it
came into existence at that time
um we are going back another 27 orders
of magnitude potentially in the
experiments that I build so the
experiments my colleagues and I build
are looking not for not for strange
particles not for new forces we're
looking for known physics the physics of
what's called gravitational radiation a
direct consequence of Einstein's theory
of general relativity
he didn't actually believe it uh
Einstein didn't believe he'd ever detect
gravitational waves he didn't believe
you ever detect gravitational lensing
you know Einstein made a lot of blunders
I don't know if you I always say it's
too bad he could have had a good career
you know he could have been somebody uh
but uh he had about seven blunders and I
always put that down as a um as a reason
that you shouldn't worship men in other
words
um we have my second book is called into
the impossible it's it's a collection of
nine of the 13 interviews I've done with
Nobel laureates and in one of those
interviews I interviewed Barry barish
who was one of the leaders of the ligo
laser interferometric gravitational wave
Observatory that detected gravitational
waves and announced it in 2016 they won
the uh the 2017 Nobel Prize that uh he
was one of the winners he told me when
he won the Nobel Prize he had the
Imposter syndrome I said why why do you
have the Imposter you won the Nobel
Prize it's the highest honor any human
scientist could ever achieve he said no
it made it worse I said why Barry
he said well when you win a Nobel Prize
you go to Stockholm Sweden you're
celebrated you're vetted you're given
feast and food and and you meet kings
and queens and you bow and you wear a
tuxedo that costs more than my first
three cars put together and when you go
there you have to
um collect your medal this is solid gold
or gold plated metal and you get a check
for your share of 1.5 million dollars US
dollars
he said when you get it they want to
prove that you're not going to come back
they trust you but they don't trust you
that much they want to make sure you're
not going to come back and say I uh
where's that check I got the medal on
stage but then they said you sign a book
Barry told me you sign a book and it
says I testify I receive my money and my
medal he said he's a curious fellow he
looked back who did he see
he saw Chandra secar he saw Feynman he
saw Madame Curie but then he saw
Einstein
he said I'm not worthy
I don't deserve to be in a book I'm just
a guy from Oklahoma I don't deserve to
be in the same
league as Einstein I don't feel worthy I
have the Imposter syndrome I said Barry
guess what Einstein felt the Imposter
syndrome
he said what are you talking about I
said Einstein felt that Isaac Newton did
more for science math physics and
Society of civilization than any other
human being before sins he said I'm not
worthy of Einstein guess what Newton had
the Imposter syndrome he wanted to be
like Jesus
but he claimed his greatest
accomplishment was that he was celibate
his whole life
and that he was like Jesus and only that
way so we all have these so never feel
like you are not as capable not as as
and actually think it does a disservice
when people have the Imposter syndrome
because you say I'm not like Einstein
I'm not like Shonda I'm not like
whatever and then you don't do the thing
that they weren't always you think
Einstein or Chandra you think they were
like that at age five you know I've got
young kids
you have to encourage them and if you
tell them you'll never be like somebody
they'll never be like anyway that's a
digression the point being
Einstein didn't believe in the expanding
Universe until he was shown physical
evidence that physical evidence was a
recessional velocities of a dozen
galaxies or so that Edwin Hubble had
observed and that he instantly in an act
of great scientific Integrity changes
mind
um and uh and so all these things that
we're looking for including Einstein's
prediction of unknowingly the existence
of waves of gravity that can be produced
if inflation took place which is what
you were inquiring about
if inflation took place there should be
unequivocally a background in space-time
ripples in space-time that are the
result perturbations in the
gravitational force field that are
produced by gravitons that exist for
infinite amounts of time just like
photons do they don't age and these
gravitons could then make their way
through the universe
to the age at which the universe was
when it produced The Cosmic microwave
background if they exist they will cause
the microwave background to inherit a
type of property called polarization
polarization is the effect of when
matter interacts or light interacts with
matter unpolarized light say from the
Sun bounces off the Pacific Ocean here
and it changes its polarization State
and suppresses some of its properties
and we observe that as a that's why we
wear polarized sunglasses when we go to
the beach
on the other hand in the early Universe
waves of gravity can polarize the CME
the cosmic micro background and we could
possibly detect it now we claimed once
before to have detected it with my
project the bicep team and that's the
subject of my first book losing the
Nobel Prize spoiler alert you know we
didn't detect it because if we detected
it we would have won a Nobel Prize
because it would have marked the
earliest physically humanly
theoretically possible moment in which
scientists could ever go back in time
it would Mark not just a second not just
a billionth of a second but a billionth
of a billionth of a billionth of a
billion 10 to the minus 36 seconds
after the big bang a couple of hundred
what's called Planck times
and that would be the earliest fossil
physical evidence we're still looking
for it that's the main goal of the
Simon's Observatory now is in Chile that
Observatory 100 million dollar project
that I co-lead with um with many of my
other fellow colleagues around the world
that project is going to get its
so-called first light or first microwave
in two years it will have capabilities
that the bicep and bicep 2 experiment
did not have and our colleagues around
the world are also looking for this
because it would be the most significant
evidence of the Big Bang but again would
it be time equals zero no we have no
thoughts on whether or not we could
distinguish time equals zero but what we
could do again our job is not to prove
the people Alan Guth Andre Linde Paul
steinhardt our job is not to prove them
right it's to prove other theories wrong
and so one of the theories that could be
proven wrong
is the existence of an earlier universe
that collapsed
like a big bounce a previous Universe
maybe an infinite cycle of cyclic
universes that come into existence
expand accelerate and then the
accelerated energy decays through some
mechanism we don't understand that the K
leads to a collapse and then that
nucleates a new Big Bang
that could happen once or an infinite
number of times but nevertheless
even if it takes one bounce or an
infinite number no waves of gravity are
produced in such a model therefore if we
see the imprint of these waves of
gravity primordial waves of gravity
we would rule out
a class of models that have been around
for over two thousand years so it's
quite exciting that we can even
contemplate to do this and we will do it
we will have answers in less than two
years
that's pretty exciting so talking about
the bicep 2 experiment uh you did not
win the Nobel Prize you thought that you
had a result that would give you the
normal price but eventually it it
emerged that there was some space dust
or something that caused you to have to
retract this so could you tell the story
about that yeah yeah it's um it is the
story of of my first book called losing
the Nobel Prize it's a story of a memoir
it's an autobiography and it explains
what goes into a building of a
scientific experiment I know that you've
talked a lot about the great
theoreticians and we've already
mentioned many of them
um including Stephen Hawking we've we've
talked about uh we talked about Einstein
earlier today
Brian Greene Lisa Randall Jenna these
are wonderful brilliant scientists guess
what they all have in common they're all
theorists they're all theoreticians I
realize there's no Book for a young
person like me even though I was
influenced by those and they're my
friends who likes to build things who
likes to work on his car who likes to do
um experiments chemistry that there was
no guidebook on how to learn about doing
actual astronomy and building actual
telescopes and how they work all you get
is the finished product there's Wormhole
and there's there's Hawking radiate but
how do you actually measure it how do
you actually build an instrument
and I wanted to do that I want to write
the first ever book about that and some
people advise me not even to talk about
the Nobel Prize because it may be
detracted from the story so actually the
Nobel Prize is only three chapters out
of 11. and most of it's about the origin
and history of how we came to believe
throughout Cosmic time that the Universe
had an origin and what it would mean to
make such a detection both
scientifically but also philosophically
maybe spiritually I am a religious
person in my case I'm a Jewish person
and that influences
um some of my philosophical but not
scientific
um Endeavors and what I decided to do
after many years of thinking I wanted to
do something very significant was to
build a tiny a small telescope it's less
than you know the width of my arms
across and I want to build a small
refracting telescope just like my great
hero Galileo did back in 1609 and that
was to build a refractor to not look at
planets not look at phases of Venus as
Galileo did but look back to the origin
of time now we couldn't use ordinary the
eyes attached to you know tubes of
telescope we had to build a microwave
telescope telescope that could see
microwaves detect them resolve their
polarization and also resolve their
electromagnetic spectrum what portion of
the spectrum that you've talked about
many times on this channel and to do so
we require to build a special kind of
detector called a superconducting
bolometer now what is a belometer it's
very simple if you go outside when it's
daytime I know it's night there but you
go outside and you close your eyes you
can still quote unquote see the sun you
can put your hand up and you'll feel the
sun's energy heating it up and that's
because the infrared or thermal energy
warms up the molecules in your hand and
so your hand is is a thermal detector so
you don't need your eyes what
superconductors do is they change their
resistance based on the amount of heat
that's hitting them they can go from a
couple of ohms what's called ohms of
resistance to zero resistance and they
can do so in a very very tiny amount of
heat and so they become an exquisitely
sensitive thermometer which when
attached to a telescope and
um and then Incorporated with it
polarizing filters becomes what's called
a polarimeter
so we built this polarimeter we realized
we couldn't have it in a beautiful place
like San Diego because what happens to
microwaves as they travel in the
universe is they can get absorbed by
water molecules that's how your
microwave oven works the water molecules
are very highly selectively absorbent to
wavelengths of electromagnetic radiation
called microwaves and so we don't want a
photon traveling for 13.8 billion years
to get absorbed in a water molecule in
the atmosphere that would be very tragic
and even though San Diego is pretty dry
especially right now there's still
tremendous amount of water vapor in our
atmosphere
so we realize my colleagues and I we
could take it to a very dry place and
that is the South Pole Antarctica the
best places in space but as you know the
web telescope which is uh not even the
biggest telescope ever made uh cost 10
billion dollars 10 times the most
expensive telescope on Earth and a
hundred or a thousand times more
expensive than the projects that I'm
working on now which will be the most so
it was prohibitive to launch it into
space so the South Pole is a dry desert
most people don't think of it because
they see the ice and they think it's uh
you know they see some penguins
splashing around but the South Pole
itself is completely desolate completely
flat completely white 9 000 feet above
sea level so it's very high altitude and
it's extremely cold so that and Chile in
the Atacama Desert which is at 5200
meters elevation 17 000 feet even higher
than the South Pole those are the two
best places to build these types of
radio telescopes now we were looking for
a signal we were looking to see if we
could see these waves of gravity in my
case as I say I wanted to win a Nobel
Prize since I was a graduate student it
was really kind of driving me I
explained in my book that it was
partially due to competition with my
father who was a great scientist that I
had been separated from because of
divorce of my parents and I wanted to
prove him wrong show him that I was a
great scientist I didn't need him it's a
it's a little dramatic but I do describe
that kind of origin story and I think
that's the most important thing you know
my birthday is coming up in just two
days and I think we're all fascinated by
birthdays and I was always fascinated by
the birth of the universe and so from
when I was a little kid I realized well
I could do this I could beat my dad I
could be a better scientist win this
Nobel Prize and by the way I'd
understand the origin of the universe
possibly have a great deal to say about
philosophy as well as science and maybe
spirituality who knows
so we built this instrument we upgraded
it like an iPhone we got new new
detectors new megapixel yeah it was
never a megapixel it's like a milli Mega
it's only 256 or 512 detectors
um that we had so it's not like an
iPhone
um but it was able to operate at 0.2
Kelvin so 0.2 degrees above absolute
zero which your I no iPhone could do
Etc so we claim we saw these waves of
gravity making an imprint on the cosmic
microwave background we announced it we
had a press conference we had a paper
but we didn't publish the paper we
didn't get a peer reviewed before we had
the press conference and this was at
Harvard the very vaunted famous most you
know probably prestigious University in
the world
after IIT which my friends tell me is
you know they call they call Harvard the
IIT of the of the west but anyway uh but
we had this announcement and we
were celebrated and it was whispered
that someone was going to win a Nobel
Prize I
Claim by that time I was already not
going to win it for reasons I get into
politics and Science and and sort of
competition
um I'll leave that leave that
non-scientific stuff out
but it was quickly realized just a few
months later
um that we had overlooked something or
we had minimized the impact of something
which is called Cosmic dust and Cosmic
dust is not that unfamiliar if you've
ever seen a meteor shower you've seen
Cosmic dust and in fact for your
listeners I know you've got millions of
listeners in the USA I can't send it
I'll try to send it to you apogee
someday or I'd rather give it to you in
person someday but for your listeners in
the USA I have a special uh offer to
thank you and that's if you join my
mailing list which is at Brian
keating.com list I will send a meteorite
to the first 100 people who join my
mailing list at Brian keating.com list
and this is a piece of space dust which
is really the villain of my book this is
a particle of matter or a chunk of
matter that has been formed four billion
500 million years ago orbited around
eventually crashed into the Earth it's
the product of a supernova explosion
that Supernova explosion
um as Chandra secar and many others
taught us is going to occur and spew out
all the materials of the nuclear fusion
process that it Formed right before it
detonates and that process is uh going
to eventually lead to the formation of
planets and the iron in our blood all
sorts of good stuff but it also makes a
smoke screen that prevents us from
seeing back to the origin of time if
we're not careful we modeled it we
thought we could understand it but there
was one team a competitor team that had
the information that we lacked which was
a higher frequency channel of
um of observation and they were located
in space this is called the Planck
satellite
they would not share the data because
either they didn't have it at the time
or they didn't want to share it with us
we'll never know but in any case we
tried to do as best we could we instead
made an assumption a model that the dust
was negligible or we could remove it
neglect it and we announced we detected
inflation
six months later the plank team worked
with us we published basically a
retraction none of the data we didn't
make a blunder we didn't leave the lens
cap on you know we didn't put our Thumb
in the in the picture no we measured an
honest-to-goodness astronomical signal
not a cosmic signal and that's what
we're trying to confront now with the
Simon's Observatory we're trying to end
the bicep array it's called this upgrade
to bicep still goes on still is making
phenomenal measurements we're trying to
measure multiple frequencies multiple
polarizations and map out whether or not
the dust signal can be subtracted from
the dust plus Cosmic signal so we're
basically doing a separate experiment of
a g we're looking just look for dust and
then we'll subtract it from the signal
that we see the combined signal and
that's what's so exciting about what my
field is doing nowadays
right now let's move on to a different
topic one that uh the audience I suppose
is very interested in something that is
at the Forefront of their minds when
when it comes to space which is aliens
and life in the universe so what are
your views about life in the universe
the origin of life whether this life in
the solar system whether there could be
intelligent life out there what do you
think about this yeah
um it's funny because I I was on a
podcast with Lex Friedman it's kind of
like the Abhijit chavara of uh of the of
of Texas now we moved to Texas
um and I got a lot of feedback some good
some negative but um my claim is that uh
that the most honest thing we can say
about aliens is that we have no evidence
for their existence and a lot of people
say things as the late great Carl Sagan
used to say
um space is enormous we know from recent
data how many galaxies there are
hundreds of billions of galaxies how
many stars there are hundreds of
billions of stars and each one of the
hundreds of billions of galaxies we know
from the Kepler satellite that there are
probably at least one or two planets
around every single one of those 100
billion squared Stars so these are
number is like 10 to the 24th a one with
24 zeros after it
um it's astronomical so therefore the
probability is quite High
um I find those arguments
um almost like wishful thinking and I do
feel like there is a spiritual component
to this wish that we would find life on
another planet it would somehow give
more meaning to the universe most of my
colleagues and I don't criticize them
are atheists they have no profess they
believe in the non-existence of God not
just that they're agnostic and they
don't have a position
um and that's fine I I think I think I
you know can accept that that's but I
think where they fail to recognize their
own shortcomings is when they believe in
things that we have no evidence for
today on my channel in about two or
three hours I'm posting an interview
with Nick Bostrom he's the creator of
What's called super intelligence which
led to What's called the simulation
hypothesis which in many people's minds
no pun intended is
um essentially a guarantee that
computing power is increasing
exponentially and it's just a matter of
time before we can simulate entire
civilizations of the past and so
therefore we should have no reason not
to think that we are not simulations
today
um and uh it's a fascinating interview
if I don't say so myself he's a deep
thinker he thinks about the dangers of
artificial intelligence and what it
could do if it became super intelligent
I think that's a form of religion too
I think there's a lot of Wishful
Thinking by scientists that there are
all sorts of of things another one is
the Multiverse we have no evidence for
the existence of another universe beyond
our Cosmic Horizon we know that's
possible but how many things are
possible
um that are actual and this is where the
alien arguments that I like to make come
into existence so one of the things that
I have access to Antarctica I've been
there I've been there twice and when I
go to Antarctica it's very difficult to
get there
in fact it wasn't discovered until the
late uh 1800s we didn't even know one of
the seven continents on earth existed
then we didn't reach the South Pole
until 100 years after that 1911 and we
finally reached the South Pole and then
we never went back again for about 50
years but be there doesn't it now if you
said to me well Brian uh there's an
awful lot of land on Earth and by the
way you didn't know about 1 7th of the
land Continental land on Earth
so therefore they're actually
underestimated how much life there
should be on Earth by a factor of
one-seventh fourteen percent call that'd
be a huge error and yet there's almost
no life there's no human life on
Antarctica once you get a couple miles
from the coast you don't even see birds
Penguins you know it kind of
disappointed me when I I want to get a
penguin you know I went back with a pet
penguin one of my kids loves them
um no there's almost no life there's no
Flora
um anywhere and and any life that's
there you know is really from somewhere
else so the point I'm trying to make is
just by saying there's so much capacity
for life in the universe has nothing to
do about the actuality about
instantiations of life in the universe
so these people that want to uh explain
not only don't forget they they our
claim the claims are and I'm involved
with with some of these projects I have
been involved with my friend Avi Loeb
his project at Harvard called the
Galileo project building telescopes to
look for Interstellar objects in our
universe in our solar system of which he
claimed he did discover
um and uh and he's on a mission to get
not a tiny meteorite like I'll send your
listeners in the USA but a huge
meteorite that crashed in from
Interstellar space into the uh South
Pacific so he's leading a million dollar
expedition to collect that now
what theirs did is very different
they're not only saying we have evidence
for some kind of bacteria in space no no
we have evidence for technology for
intelligence for
extraterrestrials that are visiting the
Earth in spacecraft that in order to get
here on a biological time scale must
suspend or modify the laws of physics so
look at all these chains of of reasoning
that you have to accept forget about all
the physical reasons that life on Earth
is so precious right and so rare
that there's a hypo Earth is basically
the only planet some say that life could
exist on
um because it has all these features one
of which
um these meteorites as I keep saying
I'll send to your listeners here in the
U.S uh on my mailing list those meteors
they come in much bigger versions
there's a power law distribution there's
some enormous ones one hit the earth 65
million years ago was called chicks alum
that was a bad day for the dinosaurs
right they they should have had a
telescope they should have had an Avi
lobe looking up in space they didn't so
that wiped them out well if they didn't
get wiped out by this meteor enormous
meteor then maybe we will not be here
asking questions as to whether or not
we're alone oh and by the way we could
there could be even more chicsalubs
there could have been literally
thousands more if we didn't have Jupiter
in the outer solar system if it was too
close it would disrupt life on Earth is
it far away look at the Moon the Moon is
filled with every single crater you see
is a direct hit on Earth well the moon
happens to be at just the right distance
it's the only moon in the solar system
that occludes the sun exactly by the
same diameter as the sun apparent
angular diameter
um uh and it has these properties that
make it a garbage collector how many
planets have those things how many
planets have a moon of that size exactly
the right size to stabilize the
processional tilt things in space would
normally just go crazy no we have stable
Seasons which allow the biological and
diurnal processes that are essential to
life so you put together these things
you say let's say there's 10 different
obstacles to creating a stream yard
platform
that to create a YouTube channel let's
say there's just 10 Things I think
there's a almost infinite number let's
just say there's 10 of them and each one
has a probability of uh one in a
thousand you know there's a one in a
thousand chance that a moon will be just
the right size just the right distance
to stabilize the procession and then
another factor is it has a Jupiter sized
planet in the outer so put them all
together and say one out of a thousand
to the to the to the tenth power so 10
to the minus three to the 10th power so
you're talking about just astronomically
small numbers that are smaller than the
number of planets in the universe in the
observable universe and I don't think I
really care if somebody told me there's
life and Andromeda I'd say that's great
for my you know two and a half million
years from now we could maybe receive a
signal from them because it's two
million five hundred thousand light
years away so all these reasons make me
very pessimistic but I don't say the
probability is zero on the other hand my
colleagues will say the probability of
God is zero and I I think that is hard
to intellectually rationalize for
someone who's an objective scientist
yeah the the question of God what do you
think about atheism and agnosticism I
mean lots of scientists are atheists do
you think it is necessary for a
scientist to be an atheist or is that
something that you don't agree with
because you said that you are a
practicing Jewish person so what's your
perspective on this
yeah I think it's a very interesting
question so if you and I were having
this conversation you know if uh stream
yard and YouTube existed you know 50
years ago it would be the exact opposite
you'd be asking me is it necessary to be
religious to be a scientist
um the purpose of Harvard University as
I said the uh the the most prestige that
was founded to teach religion to teach
uh Hebrew you couldn't graduate if you
didn't know Hebrew the language of the
Jewish people so uh it's just
interesting to note now I think the best
form of science the best form of
government the best form of society is
one that is secular that has no
religious overtones but
I think the best form of kind of moral
philosophy of thinking ethically and so
forth that belongs at least religion
belongs in the room where the
conversation is happening and to say
that there's nothing to say and that I
talk with a very famous scientist on his
podcast Lawrence Krauss last week and he
and I have talked before he's been on my
podcast
um I've talked with people uh who have a
great respect for religion uh he doesn't
he has almost no respect but we had a
respectful conversation and and the
point was you know he feels comfortable
calling all religions I'm talking Islam
Christianity Buddhism
Etc et cetera Judaism he calls them
fairy tales that we don't need because
science has invalidated I said okay
let's take that as a given but Lawrence
do you feel like your book a universe
from nothing which makes the case for
Atheism in fact the forward is written
by Richard Dawkins and it says this book
is like uh Charles Darwin Origin of
Species okay it's a little bit much and
even I think embarrasses Krauss what I
said
um this book purports to have all this
to say based on the latest findings in
science which is very untrue it's very
controversial I should say
that book
um do you want it to be relevant in a
hundred years
and he said well I like it personally
but but um but I said no if you look at
something like a science book a good
scientist should want his or her work to
be irrelevant
in five years tenure I want my work to
be totally irrelevant because I want my
students and those that come after me
that are smarter than me to stand on my
shoulders and my colleagues shoulders
and look farther into the distance
so I think it
behooves you to look at a book like
bhagavad-gita like the Torah the Jewish
Old Testament the the New Testament the
Quran whatever these books have been
around for what how long is about how
old is the bhagavad-gita
20 I'd say 2000 years we're not sure
exactly how old it is yeah
um so that book will always be relevant
unlike a science book so I want to
develop both sides of my brain the brain
side that is impertinent and and
temporary and secular and then the
Eternal philosophical
possibly spiritual side so for me they
separate I don't teach my kids the Earth
is 5782 years old as the Jewish
tradition holds I say
the Earth is billions of years old I say
the universe is more billions of years
old and I say if you believe in God do
this study science because science is
the purest translation
of the laws of nature which if you
believe in God came from God so
therefore if you want to know God's mind
there's no simpler translational
dictionary thesaurus there's nothing
more simple ironically than science so I
think religious people need to study
science in order to deepen their faith
and I think that scientists need to be
cognizant of the limitations morally and
ethically of Science and never never
equate knowledge which is what the word
science in Latin means with wisdom which
is what Sapien Homo Sapien that's what
that means so I get upset when people
say you can get wisdom from science nope
you cannot
yes science is all about empirical
evidence novel observational data that's
all it's not about wisdom which is
patterns and things like that uh now
talking about religion this a related
topic which is consciousness what are
your views on Consciousness some people
some scientists say that emotions are
chemical reactions some people believe
that uh Consciousness is an emergent
property something that emerges out of
complexity complex systems some people
say it's something that permeates the
Universe what are your views on this
Consciousness is uh one of my three big
bangs one of the three things that I am
most interested in and what do I mean by
that well we don't understand how matter
came into existence from Pure Energy we
don't understand the origin of space and
time as you and I spoke about the
beginning we don't understand it we may
never be able to understand it
furthermore we don't understand how that
inanimate matter
the hydrogen the helium
um and eventually all the other heavier
elements on the periodic table we don't
know the fundamental
um uh event that caused this inanimate
matter to become living animal animus
animal means to move so we don't
understand how that happened
then we don't understand how this living
matter bacteria became Bach you know we
came conscious thinking capable of
intellectual leaps that are timeless
uh and that's where Consciousness comes
into place that's my third Big Bang
origin of the universe origin of matter
origin of life and then origin of
Consciousness so the maybe four big
bangs then so in my estimation it's a
great mystery now is it an unsolvable
mystery I I don't know uh in in a sense
our brain has the capability to
understand itself and undo things in a
way that is not reductionally possible
to comprehend in other words
reductionists think we're just a bag of
of atoms atoms are made of protons
quarks neutral Etc we can all be reduced
to that so therefore there's a there's a
notion now in philosophy called pan
psychism Which is that all different
elements of matter participate and can
be conscious I don't believe that
um and I think that the existence of
free will
has to be taken into account we think
about Consciousness and so to the
reductionist they have had to create new
ways to explain Free Will and say that
no free will itself is an illusion it's
a manifestation of something called
determinism
and we perceive it because of either
Quantum stochastic processes or chaotic
classical processes I have an interview
with Tim Palmer who's a winner of the
Nobel Prize for climate change but he
also has a new book about chaos and the
brain and it's quite fascinating uh I've
interviewed many times sir Roger Penrose
uh he has ideas that Consciousness is a
Quantum phenomenon that originates in
certain cellular structures called
microtubules those microtubules undergo
State reduction which is what we call
Quantum uh wave function collapse I know
you've talked about this
um that process is instantiated by
gravitational Effects by effects in
space-time so it becomes that space time
itself is now correlated in a very
complicated way with the order to
collapse a wave function which then can
be perceived in a Quantum fashion now
his views along with Stuart hammeroff I
did an interview with both of them a
month ago on my channel they're not
widely accepted doesn't mean they're
wrong but many people have have claimed
to not only find holes in it but refute
it via observational evidence so it's an
open question my attitude is of course I
have free will I don't have another
choice no that's a joke
um Free Will is Manifest
um and to say that you don't opens up a
huge Pandora's Box it allows for the
denigration of the human ability to be
responsible for his or her choices and
to make decisions life or death
decisions about himself and other people
and I've never met someone who who I met
many people who believe we have no free
will but I've never met someone who acts
as if they don't have free will I think
that's very important because nobody
um you know could really function and
survive if they felt everything was
determined at the moment of the big bang
by the way we don't know if there was a
big bang right I mean this could be uh
to those that say that determinism or
super determinism is Manifest I don't
think there's any evidence for it so
will a computer ever be able to
comprehend you know Consciousness will
it ever be able to replicate
Consciousness as Nick Bostrom today's
video and my channel represents I of my
grave doubts about it and to bring this
back to where we started with Einstein
Einstein called the following the
happiest thought of his life he said if
you're freely falling if you're in an
elevator and the cable breaks or
somebody you know you get thrown up in
the air it's before Rockets existed
um and you start falling back down you
don't feel any gravitational force
it's called the equivalence principle
and uh and you don't have any notion of
uh of of accelerating whatsoever you're
in pure free fall
and he called that the happiest thought
of his life and I asked a lot of my
guests and I'll ask you uh I'll turn the
table for a second
can a computer
have a happy thought
visualize free fall
I I don't know I don't want to say
definitely not but until it could do
both of those things I don't know how we
could have an artificial Consciousness
but what do you think
so I'm not sure about that yeah it's a
good question we don't know if computers
can think we we recently have had this
news about this uh this AI in Google
it's called Lambda I believe that
actually seems to have passed the Turing
test so it does behave like a human
being you can't really tell whether it's
a human being talking to you or not but
but we're not sure it's just a
sophisticated algorithm set of
algorithms most likely so I don't know
if a computer can have emotions original
thoughts and a vision of the future a
sense of self
so we don't know it's an open question
and I don't think it's it's uh we are
there yet thus far
yeah I think we need to do a great deal
more
um investigation into both the quantum
which is the microscopic scale but
possibly into the cosmos in other words
the largest scales if there are
gravitational effects if it is true that
the brain is uh not a computer but even
if it is a computer
um as Kurt girdle showed in the 1930s
and and Alan Turing showed as well the
so-called halting process or the or the
imitation game there's a movie called
that and that was whether or not a
computer could have a finite set of
algorithms
um to prove everything that's computable
and then girdle comes along and says no
no
even math itself contains true
statements which can never be proven
therefore math is incomplete when we
physicists we are even in worse shape
and because we have no such girdle
theorem like there's no theorem a lot of
people say falsification you've probably
heard this if you can't falsify
something then it's not scientific but
that's not really except that's Carl
popper and um you know I can say that my
astrologer not my astronomer my
astrologer told me you know today's
going to be a wonderful day
um and and then I have a bad day so I
falsified what she said therefore what
she said is scientific no it's
ridiculous so
uh we have no such luck as physicists
and what is consciousness if not a
biological process what is biology if
not a chemical process and here I'm
being reductionist but what is chemistry
if not applied physics and at some level
laws of physics have to enter into the
discussion and I think we're we're in a
premature State there's so many open
questions in in quantum mechanics so
many in in cosmology it's all too hard
for me that's why I stick to something
very simple like experimental Quantum
cosmology
all right okay final question for today
uh what progress do you hope to see in
physics in cosmology in our
understanding of the universe in the
next 20 years and within this century
so I'd be you know I'd be lying if I
said I don't you know want to see
certain things with my instruments
called the Simon's observatory in Chile
um I think a good scientist should be
dispassionate and not do what I used to
do which is to be hungry to win a Nobel
Prize to become famous to do this no you
should say well this happened and we
make an observation that's what nature
is willing to show us
what I'm interested in is Building
Technology I think we have too many
theorists
don't tell my friend giant our liquor
but but really there's so much Theory
and it takes so much effort you know
there's a there's a famous law I'll make
it clean because I know you have an
audience of young people too something
called brandolini's law which is that to
refute nonsense takes 10 times more
energy than to produce nonsense so yes
I'm not calling my theorist friends
nonsensical or foolish they're much
smarter than me but it's easier in a
sense to create new theories than to
prove the existing ones wrong and again
we don't prove people right we prove
everybody else wrong as I often say and
you know Isaiah Isaac Asimov said if you
think the Earth is flat you're wrong if
you think the Earth is a perfect sphere
you're also wrong but you're less wrong
than if you think it's flat and that's
what we want to try and do we want to
keep refining and refining getting rid
of the aspects that aren't right so I I
see great interest in outside of my
field of cosmology which I'm hoping to
participate and contribute to uh in the
next uh five years to make maps of the
earliest moments of the universe's
history as well as detecting the
properties of cosmic neutrinos of dark
energy dark matter these are great
Mysteries that I think we can not prove
or disprove it's very dangerous to do
that
I think we can solve things like climate
change I think I'm very optimistic about
climate change I see it as a as a huge
opportunity for developing countries and
for developed countries to make
scientific progress and to say the best
way to combat it is shut off all carbon
right now and and just like go back to a
more primitive Society I think that's
anti-scientific because the human brain
is so adaptable so pliable so brilliant
and it's the only example of
Consciousness that we know
for sure exist
I'd be interested if aliens are
discovered I don't expect them to be
discovered but I'm certainly open to it
I'm open to even the investigations that
show the possibility for aliens to exist
not not just that they actually exist
these are fascinating subjects life in
the cosmos
um the the origin of the cosmos and then
yes Consciousness now Consciousness I
think I have the least to say in a most
pessimistic about we can't even agree
what the definition of Consciousness is
from professional Consciousness Scholars
Nick Bostrom will be on my channel as I
said in a couple hours
um he fails to come up with a concrete
definition David Chalmers who coined the
term the hard problem of Consciousness
he also says this now what do they say
and what do they believe well they both
believe in something called the
simulation hypothesis which we'll talk
about in The Matrix some other time
these topics I think point to a fact
that we're we're kind of in the you know
leeches and bloodletting stage of of
Consciousness studies you know that
medicine was in 200 years ago uh
phrenology you know studying bumps in
your head
um so those kinds of things uh are
interesting They Don't Really Turn Me On
as a scientist because I I don't feel
like I can do anything substantive in
cosmology my students my colleagues my
my collaborate they're brilliant and we
can do a lot and we'll know more
exponentially more in just a few years
and that's what's most exciting to me
right if I may add to that the one thing
that excites me the most is gravitation
and that's something we don't understand
at all so I would like to see some
progress in our understanding of gravity
the 21st century was supposed to be the
century of gravitation we still haven't
made any any Headway but let's see I
hope some progress happens absolutely
right
right so Dr Brian Keating thank you so
much for being on the podcast it's a
great pleasure and I would hope to have
you again on the podcast for the
audience uh Dr keating's links are in
the description below go ahead follow
him by his books thank you Dr Keating
and yeah have a good day thank you very
much and don't forget if you're in the
USA someday I'll bring some to India and
around the world but if you go to my
mailing list Brian keating.com list
you'll get uh subscribed to my mailing
list I send out cool information about
my colleagues and my scientific exploits
as well as win a chance of 100
meteorites that I'll send to you uh in
the mail so hopefully I'll do that it's
been a great honor to be with you
thank you bye